hello everyone welcome to this week's
episode of good gaming news i've given
it a name and now i have a little logo
look at us go um this is a weekly show
where i go over a few gaming news
stories over the week that i feel
positively about because i feel like
there are enough angry gaming news
videos on youtube i don't want to
contribute to those unless i feel like i
have something relevant to say or
different to say or something that
people have not already screamed 100
times um and not enough positive gaming
news videos of course it'll never get a
lot of views because it's not angry but
that's okay i have a full-time job i
don't need views and i am cheating at
the start of this episode i am cheating
if you miss this news this is very very
big news that dropped yesterday or this
morning yesterday that pertains to uh
embrace a group making more and more and
more acquisitions um on top of an
already very surprising amount of
acquisitions and my general response to
this is i feel a little bit unsettled by
it i don't love any company scooping up
a whole bunch of ip in the industry i
don't like what it does for the
competitive nature of the industry there
are a lot of things that i don't like
about it however there are some
positives in here which is what i wanted
to talk about if you missed the news
embracer group makes more acquisitions
including the hobbit and lord of the
rings ip this is on
videogameschronicle.com these are the
ones that everybody's using in their
headlines um but as they mentioned here
new deals include limited run games
which really surprised me tuxedo labs
tripwire interactive and an undisclosed
company which i wonder who that is
that's an exciting one if you haven't
heard of embracer group let me pull up
there i've never actually looked at
their website before this is
so
corporate this is such a corporate ass
games company website wow embracer group
is the parent company of businesses
developing and publishing pc console and
moving games to the global games market
an ecosystem for entrepreneurial
companies in the gaming and
entertainment industry yeah this is 100
a corporate website wow and this is a
list of mergers and acquisitions by
embracing groups racing group is a
swedish video game company controlled by
lars wing fours as of 2021 they own more
than 76 internal studios in over 45
countries
subsidiaries are organized under 10
groups amplifier game invest as modi
coffee stain holding dark horse media
deca games easy brain gearbox
entertainment play on saber interactive
and thq nordic this explains it pretty
well each group has its own operation
areas and game development studios so
it's pretty huge and these list of
acquisitions like the november
acquisitions
it's just it's only been getting bigger
and bigger and bigger they just keep
doing it this month we have tripwire
interactive tripwire most recently made
a man-eater i believe but you'd also
know them from
rising storm killing floor tuxedo labs
is a swedish studio who made a teardown
plus middle earth enterprises limited
run games that's like a pretty big one
they're effectively like an indie
distributor but i love i love limited
run they do great work uh bit wave games
geotech string tricks and tatsujin
um and that is on top of crystal
dynamics idos montreal and square enix
montreal which was of course a 300
million dollar deal it's a lot of
acquisitions it's a lot of movement for
one company and
again there are a lot of things i don't
like about this
but what i do like about it including um
lord of the rings
certainly including square enix
is that you don't generally buy ip
unless you want to make stuff with that
ip it seemed pretty clear that square
again seemingly was not interested in
making any more deus ex for example now
that that is under embracer it's pretty
likely that that ip will be reactivated
as it were we don't know the quality of
the kind of games that embracer is
trying to make but you're pretty well
guaranteed to assume that they are
going to go for a high bar after having
made all these acquisitions and then
having to prove to all of their
investors that those are worthwhile it's
a gross way of thinking about things but
the first games that you
make under the ips that you've spent so
much money on kind of have to be
critically impressive are well received
by player bases so you can report those
findings back to your shareholders and
then later if you intend to probably not
from the jump because you don't want to
burn your reputation too fast is when
you start over monetizing making more
money
micro transactions nfts whatever else
that's where that comes in if it does
that's not to say they ever will do that
stuff i'm just hopeful optimistic that
that stuff will not happen from the
start and again that's where i see the
positivity is in the potential for some
of these ip to actually be worked on
again middle earth enterprises is an
interesting one too um of course again
everyone's really talking about hobbit
and a lot of the rings which is a pretty
specific deal it's still like it doesn't
control like the silmarillion or a lot
of other tolkien work but it does give
embrace a group a vast intellectual
property catalogue and worldwide rights
to motion pictures video games board
games merchandising theme parks and
stage productions relating to the iconic
fantasy literary works the lord of the
rings trilogy and the hobbit by j.r.r
tolkien their
actual agreement here
includes a quote from the ceo that says
i am truly excited to have the lord of
the rings and the hobbit one of the
world's most epic fantasy franchises
join the embracer family opening up more
transmedia opportunities including
synergies across our global group i am
thrilled to see what lies in the future
for this ip with free mode and asmody as
a start within the group going forward
we will also look forward to
collaborating with both existing and new
external licensees of our increasingly
popular or sorry stronger ip portfolio
and it's sort of interesting because um
the lord of the rings
golem game
is of course currently in development
and
doesn't look great
this is not a great looking game from
this trailer unfortunately i'm not super
hot on how it looks um
both graphically but i also feel like it
just
it just looks a little bit dated
in terms of gameplay as well um and i
love this world i i love a lot of a lot
of the rings games i think are very good
and i feel like a lot of fan reception
to this is quite negative
which could mean when you have an
acquisition that uh the quality of this
game is improved upon before it's
released and gollum did get delayed
daedalic entertainment needs a bit more
time to polish the lord of the rings
prequel and announced another golem
delay so team has time to finish it this
story is for pc games in case you missed
it and i assume is related to this
acquisition to be fair nikon and
daedalic entertainment announced another
golem delay to help give the team more
time to polish the new lord of the rings
game dalek originally planned to release
golem in summit 2022 before pushing at
the stealth games launch to september in
a new delay announcement they said they
plan to release it in a few months so we
don't actually have any release date
we're just assuming 2023. and again this
could very easily be a situation where
the quality is improved by the
acquisition similar what happened with
batgirl sometimes a ceo comes in and
says i need my portfolio to be strong
from the jump i do not want anything
associated with me and my takeover of
this company and my takeover of this ip
to be
in any way received poorly so it either
gets axed completely or is probably
given even more time to up the quality
which um i don't know again i've loved a
lot of lord of the rings games i'm
stoked to have that they did also say
other opportunities include exploring
additional movies based on iconic
characters such as gandalf aragon golem
galadriel eowyn and other characters
from the literary works of jr tolkien
and continue to provide new
opportunities for fans to explore this
fictive world through merchandising and
other experiences so yes
a lot of acquisitions out here from
embracer and there are good sides and
bad sides um mostly a lot of curiosity
right now but i do feel positively about
some of this ip i feel positively about
thief i feel positively about deus ex
and i am hopeful for um improvements to
gollum now for some objectively good
gaming news this next story
rules so hard this article is on uh
tomshardware.com leaked nvidia ceo memo
assures no layoffs after disappointing
quarter too the company is seemingly
doubling down on its commitment to
employees nvidia's q2 results were far
from the shot in the arm the company
needed to distance itself from the
overall tech industry slippage unlike
amd
which surpassed already positive
expectations with a revenue of 6.7
billion which is lower than expectations
which placed it at 8.1 billion it's 21
lower that's pretty significant nvidia
employees were obviously left wondering
how solid their positions were
especially considering macroeconomic
factors such as rampant inflation to
clear the air nvidia ceo jensen huang
penned an internal memo to employees
that aim to put them at rest there are
no planned layoffs in fact nvidia is
doubling down on its commitment to the
talent that has led it to be one of the
industry's juggernauts and again if this
were just like a press release or
something i guess it's possible that
this was uh intentionally
um
leaked i suppose by the means of
delivery
it seems like this is just a genuinely
good thing to do um so to quote the
email so what does this mean for us do
we have a layoff no instead we have
given raises to take care of your
families as all of you are facing
sky-high inflation this never happens
he wrote in the memo
shared by business insider of course
having a plan is a sure way of having to
change it so while there are no planned
layoffs at the moment they could happen
eventually and the strategy could be
revised at a later date wong reiterated
that the company's strategy would focus
on streamlining existing processes and
materials usage instead of cutbacks we
will exercise extreme collaboration a
hallmark about culture finding every
opportunity to leverage and reuse we
will find and eliminate all wasted time
process and material take this
opportunity to make nvidia even faster
leaner and agile which does sound like
layoffs but straight up this is like a
ceo being like hey you're all getting
raises i understand it's been bad but
we're gonna figure it out by reassessing
what's going on in the company and
what's costing too much and it's not you
uh juan closed out its email with
remarks on the company's strategy for
future growth opportunities as you do
including artificial intelligence and
murder verse related pursuits which i
don't know if that's really what where
you want to want to go have you seen
that have you seen this this
this is an image that
mark zuckerberg posted for his avatar in
the metaverse uh when he
announced i think it's like paris and
mark zuckerberg posted a vr selfie from
inside his company's metaverse project
horizon worlds the selfie showed off the
eiffel tower and was meant to announce
that his metaverse is expanding to more
countries
that's
that's how it looks
i don't know about that one chief but
the metaverse does require extreme
graphical computing power to enable
digital experiences which obviously
leans into nvidia's strengths so yeah i
just thought that this was awesome um i
hope that it stands i hope they do not
have layoffs
i hope that this doesn't age like milk
it can happen
so for the last good story of the week
i think this is awesome
make myself smaller
popular pc mod sites ban homophobic mods
for insomniacs spider-man uh nexus mods
and mod db both specifically removed
users
for
basically people modded the game to
remove every pride flag which is just
why insomniac's marvel's spider-man
recently made the jump from playstation
exclusivity to windows pc just as sony's
god of war did earlier this year
naturally the game has attracted some
attention from the modding community who
now has the freedom to transform
spider-man into kingpin and other
characters i think i saw somebody do
stan lee seeing some of the mods has
been really fun here let me show you
some cool ones uh they made a miles
morales mod a may parker mod
i love that so much there is a kingpin
mod this one uh went kind of viral this
is so funny
i love that pictoria flag wow look at
you go your little meme lords this flag
is a direct reference to one of the most
popular episodes of family guy where
peter declares his house as a country
within america and becomes its president
oh this mod lets you make it rain
whenever you want that's cool um you can
get overcast days rainy nights and even
watery sunsets
yeah turn rtx on that's gonna make some
beautiful screenshots this one i had
also heard about which is one of my
favorites for sure is movie style
reshade is what they're calling it it
effectively gives the game like more
movie-like visuals you get a version of
spider-man remastered that feels like
it's right out of sam rimey's raymie
spiderman movies no hud that's cool
that's really cool i'd love to try that
um so definitely some cool mods uh but
of course because the internet some
modders took this newfound freedom for
granted targeting the various pride
flags scattered around marvel
spider-man's new york and replacing them
with american flags thankfully popular
mod sites nexus mods and montbe have
taken a stand against this behavior
which again i just think is so cool on
thursday nexus mods released a big blog
on its site in which it addressed so
this is the blog post from nexus mods
who said recently there's been some
silly drama on our site that was sparked
by someone uploading a mod for
spider-man remastered the mod replaced
the very few pride flags that the game
actually has with the already prevalent
usa flag texture from the game the mod
was removed from nexus mods and the
author was banned to address the banning
which a lot of people want to focus on
the mod was uploaded by a sock puppet
account so it was a newly made account
anyway
and uploaded under the name mike hawke
that doesn't work in an australian
accent because we pronounce the w
hawk
uh it was very clearly done deliberately
to be a troll mod the fact that the user
needed to make a sock puppet like a
coward to upload the mod show their
intent troll and that they knew it would
not be allowed had they not been a
coward and had used their main account
instead we would have simply removed the
mod and told them that we did not want
to host it only banning them if they
re-uploaded it again after being fairly
warned the creation of the sock puppet
removed any doubt and made it very easy
decision for us both the self-puppet
account and the user's main account have
been banned in regards to the
replacement of pride flags in the game
or any game our policy is thus we are
for inclusivity we are for diversity if
we think someone is uploading a modern
outside with the intent to deliberately
be against inclusivity and or diversity
then we will take action against it same
goes for people attempting to troll
others with mods deliberately to cause a
rise for our part we will endeavor to do
a better job of moderating our website
to this ethos ourselves this is a really
good statement
it's a really good statement i
appreciate the clarity and this is an
important note here too we aren't the
authority on what users can and cannot
mod us removing a mod only means it
cannot be found at nexus mods nothing
more nothing less they're not cancelling
this mod
it's not a freedom of speech issue it
just means that this particular website
was like nope not what we stand for get
out of here
which i think is great as they say here
oh hello welcome hi handsome
you want some good news gaming too as a
private business we have the right to
choose what content we do and do not
want to host on our platform respect the
respect this right the same way you want
respect for your rights which is also an
important thing to note because i'm sure
people are screaming about cancer
culture we don't want to and won't argue
this with you we've now explained our
stance and we won't be providing a
platform for you to distort our position
in order to feed an irrational and
paranoid narrative you could do that
elsewhere where we won't care enough to
read it let me go on to say if this
policy upsets you if we've broken some
moral code of conduct as a business that
you can't accept then please delete your
account and move on as we will i just
love it i just i just think this is like
hey this is shitty get out you've been
removed that's it if you don't like it
also get out like i think that's totally
fair and awesome like to just snap down
on it and take a stance that hard is
like
so mod db obviously also did the same
thing a few hours later when a fan
tweeted evidence of the mod that
specifically targeted targeted and this
is a quote stupid pride flags um i
believe that was on the mod listing
again clearly hateful and the mod db
twitter account tweeted that the site
banned the users who created the mod and
removed the content saying mod db is
inclusive environment for all and we do
not permit targeting marginalized groups
they assured fans that while its
moderation tools are automated the site
will continue to take content like this
down if alerted to it there are so many
cool mods that you can use that are fun
and exciting why would you create one
and advertise one that takes down stupid
flags for a minority group and if you're
upset by them existing in the game
my god there are so many other things
for you to worry about you know
that is it for this week's good gaming
news everybody thank you for watching i
will see you next week bye